Like that earlier image, we saw lots of animals.
Now there's almost none.
The tundra is mostly moss, and then there's the boreal forest.
And that's the way it is, folks. There's just a few animals there.
So they brought in a lot of grazing animals:
musk ox, Yakutian horses, they're bringing in some bison,
they're bringing in some more now,
and put them in at the density that they used to be.
And grasslands are made by grazers.
So these animals are there, grazing away,
and they're doing a couple of things.
First of all, they're turning the tundra, the moss, back into grassland.
Grassland fixes carbon.
Tundra, in a warming world, is thawing and releasing a lot of carbon dioxide
and also methane.
So already in their little 25 square miles,
they're doing a climate stabilization thing.
Part of that story, though,
is that the boreal forest is very absorbent to sunlight,
even in the winter when snow is on the ground.
And the way the mammoth steppe,
which used to wrap all the way around the North Pole --
there's a lot of landmass around the North Pole --
that was all this grassland.
And the steppe was magnificent,
probably one of the most productive biomes in the world,
the biggest biome in the world.
The forest part of it, right now, Sergey Zimov and Nikita
go out with this old military tank they got for nothing,
and they knock down the trees.
And that's a bore, and it's tiresome,
and as Sergey says, "... and they make no dung!"
which, by the way, these big animals do, including mammoths.
So mammoths become what conservation biologists call
an umbrella species.
It's an exciting animal -- pandas in China or wherever --
that the excitement that goes on of making life good for that animal
is making a habitat, an ecosystem,
which is good for a whole lot of creatures and plants,
and it ideally gets to the point of being self-managing,
where the conservation biologists can back off and say,
"All we have to do is keep out the destructive invasives,
and this thing can just cook."
CA: So there's many other species that you're dreaming of de-extincting
at some point,
but I think what I'd actually like to move on to
is this idea you talked about how mammoths might help
green Siberia in a sense,
or at least, I'm not talking about tropical rainforest,
but this question of greening the planet you've thought about a lot.
And the traditional story is
that deforestation is one of the most awful curses
of modern times,
and that it's a huge contributor to climate change.
And then you went and sent me this graph here, or this map.
What is this map?
SB: Global greening.
The thing to do with any narrative that you get from headlines
and from short news stories
is to look for what else is going on,
and look for what Marc Andreessen calls "narrative violation."
So the narrative -- and Al Gore is master of putting it out there --
is that there's this civilization-threatening
climate change coming on very rapidly.
We have to cease all extra production of greenhouse gases, especially CO2,
as soon as possible,
otherwise, we're in deep, deep trouble.
All of that is true, but it's not the whole story,
and the whole story is more interesting than these fragmentary stories.
Plants love CO2.
What plants are made of is CO2 plus water via sunshine.
And so in many greenhouses, industrialized greenhouses,
they add CO2 because the plants turn that into plant matter.
So the studies have been done with satellites and other things,
and what you're seeing here is a graph of, over the last 33 years or so,
there's 14 percent more leaf action going on.
There's that much more biomass.
There's that much more what ecologists call "primary production."
There's that much more life happening,
thanks to climate change,
thanks to all of our goddam coal plants.
So -- whoa, what's going on here?
By the way, crop production goes up with this.
This is a partial counter
to the increase of CO2,
because there's that much more plant that is sucking it down
into plant matter.
Some of that then decays and goes right back up,
but some of it is going down into roots
and going into the soil and staying there.
So these counter things are part of what you need to bear in mind,
and the deeper story is
that thinking about and dealing with and engineering climate
is a pretty complex process.
It's like medicine.
You're always, again, tweaking around with the system
to see what makes an improvement.
Then you do more of that, see it's still getting better,
then -- oop! -- that's enough, back off half a turn.
CA: But might some people say, "Not all green is created equal."
Possibly what we're doing is trading off the magnificence of the rainforest
and all that diversity
for, I don't know, green pond scum or grass or something like that.
SB: In this particular study, it turns out every form of plant is increasing.
Now, what's interestingly left out of this study
is what the hell is going on in the oceans.
Primary production in the oceans,
the biota of the oceans, mostly microbial,
what they're up to is probably the most important thing.
They're the ones that create the atmosphere
that we're happily breathing,
and they're not part of this study.
This is one of the things James Lovelock has been insisting;
basically, our knowledge of the oceans, especially of ocean life,
is fundamentally vapor, in this sense.
So we're in the process of finding out
by inadvertent bad geoengineering of too much CO2 in the atmosphere,
finding out, what is the ocean doing with that?
Well, the ocean, with the extra heat,
is swelling up.
That's most of where we're getting the sea level rise,
and there's a lot more coming with more global warming.
We're getting terrible harm to some of the coral reefs,
like off of Australia.
The great reef there is just a lot of bleaching from overheating.
And this is why I and Danny Hillis, in our previous session on the main stage,
was saying, "Look, geoengineering is worth experimenting with enough
to see that it works,
to see if we can buy time in the warming aspect of all of this,
tweak the system with small but usable research,
and then see if we should do more than tweak.
CA: OK, so this is what we're going to talk about
for the last few minutes here
because it's such an important discussion.
First of all, this book was just published by Yuval Harari.
He's basically saying the next evolution of humans is to become as gods.
I think he --
SB: Now, you've talked to him. And you've probably finished the book.
I haven't finished it yet.
Where does he come out on --
CA: I mean, it's a pretty radical view.
He thinks that we will completely remake ourselves
using data, using bioengineering,
to become completely new creatures
that have, kind of, superpowers,
and that there will be huge inequality.
But we're about to write a very radical, brand-new chapter of history.
That's what he believes.
SB: Is he nervous about that? I forget.
CA: He's nervous about it,
but I think he also likes provoking people.
SB: Are you nervous about that?
CA: I'm nervous about that.
But, you know, with so much at TED, I'm excited and nervous.
And the optimist in me is trying hard to lean towards
"This is awesome and really exciting,"
while the sort of responsible part of me is saying,
"But, uh, maybe we should be a little bit careful
as to how we think of it."
SB: That's your secret sauce, isn't it, for TED?
Staying nervous and excited.
CA: It's also the recipe for being a little bit schizophrenic.
But he didn't quote you.
What I thought was an astonishing statement that you made
right back in the original Whole Earth Catalog,
you ended it with this powerful phrase:
"We are as gods, and might as well get good at it."
And then more recently, you've upgraded that statement.
I want you talk about this philosophy.
SB: Well, one of the things I'm learning is that documentation
is better than memory -- by far.
And one of the things I've learned from somebody --
I actually got on Twitter.
It changed my life -- it hasn't forgiven me yet!
And I took ownership of this phrase when somebody quoted it,
and somebody else said,
"Oh by the way, that isn't what you originally wrote
in that first 1968 Whole Earth Catalog.
You wrote, 'We are as gods and might as well get used to it.'"
I'd forgotten that entirely.
The stories -- these goddam stories -- the stories we tell ourselves
become lies over time.
So, documentation helps cut through that.
It did move on to "We are as gods and might as well get good at it,"
and that was the Whole Earth Catalog.
By the time I was doing a book called "Whole Earth Discipline:
An Ecopragmatist Manifesto,"
and in light of climate change, basically saying that we are as gods
and have to get good at it.
CA: We are as gods and have to get good at it.
So talk about that, because the psychological reaction
from so many people as soon as you talk about geoengineering
is that the last thing they believe is that humans should be gods --
some of them for religious reasons,
but most just for humility reasons,
that the systems are too complex,
we should not be dabbling that way.
SB: Well, this is the Greek narrative about hubris.
And once you start getting really sure of yourself,
you wind up sleeping with your mother.
(Laughter)
CA: I did not expect you would say that.
SB: That's the Oedipus story.
Hubris is a really important cautionary tale to always have at hand.
One of the guidelines I've kept for myself is:
every day I ask myself how many things I am dead wrong about.
And I'm a scientist by training
and getting to work with scientists these days,
which is pure joy.
Science is organized skepticism.
So you're always insisting
that even when something looks pretty good,
you maintain a full set of not only suspicions
about whether it's as good as it looks,
but: What else is going on?
So this "What else is going?" on query,
I think, is how you get away from fake news.
It's not necessarily real news,
but it's welcomely more complex news
that you're trying to take on.
CA: But coming back to the application of this just for the environment:
it seems like the philosophy of this is that, whether we like it or not,
we are already dominating so many aspects of what happens on planets,
and we're doing it unintentionally,
so we really should start doing it intentionally.
What would it look like to start getting good at being a god?
How should we start doing that?
Are there small-scale experiments or systems we can nudge and play with?
How on earth do we think about it?
SB: The mentor that sort of freed me
from total allegiance to Buckminster Fuller
was Gregory Bateson.
And Gregory Bateson was an epistemologist and anthropologist and biologist
and psychologist and many other things,
and he looked at how systems basically look at themselves.
And that is, I think, part of how you want to always be looking at things.
And what I like about David Keith's approach to geoengineering
is you don't just haul off and do it.
David Keith's approach --
and this is what Danny Hillis was talking about earlier --
is that you do it really, really incrementally,
you do some stuff to tweak the system, see how it responds,
that tells you something about the system.
That's responding to the fact that people say, quite rightly,
"What are we talking about here?
We don't understand how the climate system works.
You can't engineer a system you don't understand."
And David says, "Well, that certainly applies to the human body,
and yet medicine goes ahead, and we're kind of glad that it has."
The way you engineer a system that is so large and complex
that you can't completely understand it
is you tweak it,
and this is kind of an anti-hubristic approach.
This is: try a little bit here,
back the hell off if it's an issue,
expand it if it seems to go OK,
meanwhile, have other paths going forward.
This is the whole argument for diversity and dialogue and all these other things
and the things we were hearing about earlier with Sebastian [Thrun].
So the non-hubristic approach is looking for social license,
which is a terminology that I think is a good one,
of including society enough
in these interesting, problematic, deep issues
that they get to have a pretty good idea
and have people that they trust paying close attention
to the sequence of experiments as it's going forward,
the public dialogue as it's going forward --
which is more public than ever, which is fantastic --
and you feel your way,
you just ooze your way along,
and this is the muddle-through approach that has worked pretty well so far.
The reason that Sebastian and I are optimistic is we read
people like Steven Pinker, "The Better Angels of Our Nature,"
and so far, so good.
Now, that can always change,
but you can build a lot on that sense of: things are capable of getting better,
figure out the tools that made that happen and apply those further.
That's the story.
CA: Stewart, I think on that optimistic note,
we're actually going to wrap up.
I am in awe of how you always are willing to challenge yourself
and other people.
I feel like this recipe for never allowing yourself to be too certain
is so powerful.
I want to learn it more for myself,
and it's been very insightful and inspiring, actually,
listening to you today.
Stewart Brand, thank you so much.
SB: Thank you.
(Applause)